ganz genau und zwar habe ich mich
unfassbar über das junge format funk
aufgesägt des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks zwar gab es ja vor einiger
zeit aufregungen um die moderatorin enie
passant sie sollte eigentlich eine
mutation
machen für das wissenschaftsmagazin
quarks für das wdr der wdr wollte das
aber nicht machen bei herauskam dass sie
auf der antisemitischen als damon mit
marschiert ist und auf instagram stark
für diese inhalte gelegt hat auch
anti-israelische
der wdr hat daraufhin die zusammenarbeit
komplett beendet aber was jetzt passiert
ist
nämlich al hassan darf weiter moderieren
oder weiter heißt seien für eine krems
sendung des jungen formats punkt
das zdf begründet das damit dass
hier keine schweren vorwürfe vorliegen
würden und wenn ja auch egal muss nicht
so gefasst darauf eingehen aber auf
jeden fall das regt mich unfassbar auf
weil es ja die ganze zeit dass wir uns
positionieren müssen gegen
antisemitismus und ich habe einfach
keine lust gebühren zu zahlen für
menschen oder inhalte die permanent
gegen den staat israel hetzen und noch
ein kleiner zusatz das ist nicht der
einzelfall das geplatzte formate von
funk in denen regelmäßig der stadt
israel dämonisiert wird in dem die da
die kahlen tendenzen im islam und vor
allem die gewalt gegen frauen komplett
rot geschrieben und ja dass ich ziemlich
auf mich auch und ich glaube es gibt es
zusammenhänge zwischen die drei themen
die wir jetzt am ende besprochen haben
ich glaube man hat das thema migration
das thema migranten das thema menschen
mit migrationshintergrund zu einem oral
thema gemacht das bedeutet es reicht
eigentlich meine migrationhintergrund
als
qualifizierung um irgendwo alles als
bild für vielfalt und wie toleranz etf
von der ag sind die gesamten
sendungen vor allem bei funk sind
teilweise mit islamisten besitz mit
menschen die immer wieder sozusagen
werbung für religion machen statt dass
sie kritisch dass auch betrachten statt
dass sie auch andere stimmen auch
erlauben das thema israel palästina wird
immer wieder sehr einseitig betrachtet
man zelebriert sich als opfer man redet
über rassismus wie gesagt auch als eine
einbahnstraße das sind alle inhalte die
mir große sorgen machen dann ein land
muss auch in der lage sein ihre werte zu
verteidigen
und wenn man hier von nie wieder immer
wieder spricht darf das nicht nur in
sonntagsreden und mahnwachen bleiben
sondern das muss auch folgen und
maßnahmen haben und eine diese maßnahmen
antisemiten ganz klar zu sagen wir haben
in diesem land keinen platz und vor
allem wir haben beim von steuergelder
finanzierten öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunk kein platz ja auf jeden fall
also es sieht man ja wohin wohin diese
identitätspolitik führt also diese
formate bei von jetzt zum beispiel
attentäter die werben ja wirklich nicht
immer erklären was es dazu dass die
täter ja genau ich wollte gerade
erklären also es sind eher junge junge
muslime die darüber berichten wie es ist
in deutschland im exil zu sein
muslimische eltern zu haben auch ein
paar herrlichen anders nicht mit dabei
auf ihre muslimische identität
bezeichnen aber die frage woher du woher
kommst du alles eine rassistische frage
das sind gruppierungen mit denen habe
ich mich sehr und den film auseinander
gesetzt die einseitig sehr kritisch die
mehrheit gesellschaft betrachten aber
wenn es um islam themen islamismus vor
allem super unkritisch einseitig das ist
eigentlich nicht anders als eine werbung
für eine religion den offensichtlichen
sein ich habe mich ja auch mal länger
mit funk beschäftigt dazu was größeres
geschrieben in der neuen zürcher zeitung
kleine korrektur ist in die steuergelder
sondern beitragsgelder die aber
praktisch gehalten
und ich glaube das problem ist bei so
ein mit diesem sender ist dass man
wirklich als verlautbarungsorgan von
linken widmen wenn man heute sagt sich
begreift als ist eine weltanschauung die
sich dort in 60 70 verschiedenen
formaten darstellt und das ist glaube
ich schon ein problem also als wäre es
links automatisch beispielsweise um den
israel palästina konflikt mit der brille
eines linken anti imperialisten und
antikapitalisten zu betrachten und
antwort und antisemiten dann komme ich
gleich zu einer dämonisierung israels
und für eine dämonisierung israels aus
linker antikapitalistischer perspektiv
ist es nicht weit zum antisemitismus das
heißt das problem ist diese
unausgewogenheit dieses senders funk ich
glaube man wird auch den jugendlichen
nicht gerecht und ich möchte an die
öffentlich-rechtlichen hier nicht nur
schlechte arbeit machen appellieren
traut euch doch da wirklich mal echte
vielfalt zuzulassen kontroverse vor
allem ich meine auch diese linke
meinung hat auch ihre berechtigung das
ist auch völlig in ordnung geht viel
auch die enge getrieben aber die darf
nicht alleine stehen man muss auch in
diesem gesellschaft endlich sich
kontroverse zutrauen dass
unterschiedliche meinungen zugelassen
und nicht alles was einen millimeter von
die linke backe abweicht alles
populismus und rechtsradikal bezeichnet
das geht nicht und das will ich ja dass
junge menschen wenn sie sich anschauen
ernst nehmen denken ja so gehört es sich
hier ja da muss man halt sein wenn man
links ist muss man sollte aufgestellt
eingestellt sein wahlrecht für alle zum
beispiel war eine forderung dort in
einem beitrag wahlrecht für alle die
hier sind da habe ich ein riesiges
problem mit dem grundgesetz mit dem
staatsbürger eigentlich das problem auch
dass wir in deutschland auf den
antisemitismus von muslimischer seite
viel weniger stark reagieren als auf den
übrigen antisemitismus auf den mann zwar
rechtfertige gehen aber rechtfertigt
haben so dass dieses liegt ihm doch
zugrunde sicher ja natürlich also in
genau das kommt ja eben von dieser von
dieser sehr plumpen zweiteilung der welt
also man sieht die gefahr eigentlich nur
im rechtsextremismus und muslime sind
per se opfer die ja fantastisch muss man
darf selbst nicht mehr fragen woher
kommst du weil dann ergänzt man den
anderen schon als den anderen aus dann
ist es eigentlich schon rassistischer
gewalt und auf der anderen seite ist es
kein problem wenn man die gewalt und das
finde ich eigentlich schlimmste an funk
dass man wirklich sendungen hat mit
jungen staunen jungen muslimen die sehr
sich sehr sehr streng verschleiert sind
und sagen ja im islam ist überhaupt kein
problem sexualität im islam ist über
flirten es auch überhaupt gar kein stück
die entscheidung ist kein problem und
dann denke ich mir um gottes willen sie
haben in deutschland so ein großes
problem mit jungen musliminnen die nicht
aus diesen werken sony ericsson aber das
meinte ich sowas bank an der sendung die
das wird nicht kritisch betrachtet es
ist auch völlig in ordnung so eine
meinung zu haben aber ich stelle dann
die frage wo ist die anderen stimmen wo
sind wir die islamkritiker sogenannten
ich bin kein islamkritiker diejenigen
die probleme sehen die herausforderungen
der integration man hat uns abseits
bewegt man hat uns da muss ich mir also
sie werden ja auch in alle tv sendungen
eingeladen also sitzen hier das ist noch
im öffentlichen rechtlichen fernsehen
ist ja nicht so dass ihre meinung nicht
gehört würde also das kann man nichts
sagt also das erleben wie holz eine
andere meinung vertreten nicht dabei
sind finde ich etwas übertrieben
dargestellt also erstmal bin ich dankbar
in einem land zu sein wo ich
mitgestalten darf und es geht jetzt in
die tiefe beschreibung nicht um mich ich
lebe übrigens unter personenschutz dh es
ist nicht einfach bestimmte themen
kritisch zu betrachten es gibt aber
kollegen von mir die leiden darunter die
werden teilweise nicht eingeladen zu
veranstaltungen ich merke auch dass sie
zugang zum beispiel zu universitäten
nicht mehr vorhanden die einladungen die
vor fünf sechs jahren da waren kommen
kaum ich will mich nicht beklagen ich
bin kein opfer ich will in einem land
leben wo kontroverse zugelassen wird und
menschen nicht abgestempelt werden weil
sie eine andere gunnar schupelius wie
kriegen wir mehr kontroverse in die
durch mut also dass wir selber uns immer
wieder trauen unsere meinung zu äußern
dass das letzte jahr stark nach die
leute haben ja sozusagen vorauseilen
schon das gefühl sie sollten nichts mehr
sagen das drückt sich in den umfragen
auf aus aber wir merken das auch als
journalistin glaube ich trifft betrifft
auch unsere berufsgruppe selber dass wir
journalisten uns
trauen sollten unsere meinung zu sagen
auch wenn sie kontrovers ist das einzige
gegenmittel nicht also was was sollen
wir denn sonst machen denn wir sehen ja
das verschwinden der vielfalt wir reden
alle von vielfalt aber die vielfalt geht
verloren sie haben es gesagt innerhalb
von wenigen jahren kriegt man weniger
einladungen wenn man anderer meinung ist
das geht ja rapide abwärts also wir
gehen ja wir gehen ja schon passiert
dass ich wegen meiner meinung
diskriminiert worden sind ja
selbstverständlich also nicht einmal
sondern also sozusagen praktisch täglich
ja also ich ja ich habe mich daran
gewöhnt dass ich wegen einer
meinungsäußerung nicht also das nicht
auf meiner meinungsäußerung reagiert
wird sondern dass ich wieder gemacht
werde also dass ich
nach dem motto des sollte dies sollte es
eigentlich gar nicht geben also das ist
so die die klassische reaktion die ich
erlebe wenn ich eine meinung äußere die
die nicht im mainstream ist und und und
was ich was ich mir eigentlich er hoffe
immer dass das sich eine gegenmeinung
habe auf die ich auch wieder reagieren
kann so wie sie es gesagt haben wer also
wir das meinungen sind dazu da dass man
sie austausch der debatte heißt dass man
wie im sport
sich also schaut wer jetzt